LOOKS CAN'T SEE THEMSELVES IN
THE YEAR.
SOFTWARE AND IS NOT HIS STRONG
SUIT.
IT USED TO BE EASY TO REMEMBER
THE THINGS IN AMERICA THAT WERE
RACIST.
THEY WERE OBVIOUS THINGS.
BURNING CROSSES, WEARING WHITE
ROBES, SWASTIKAS.
YOU GET THE POINT.
NOW ALMOST EVERY DAY SOMETHING
NEW IS BEING DECLARED RACIST BY
WHOEVER DECIDES WHAT'S RACIST.
BETSY ROSS IS NONRACIST FOR THE
NATIONAL RACIST.
AND NOW AS OF THIS WEEK, ONE OF
AMERICA'S FIRST FLAGS, THE
GASTON FLAY, THE ONE THAT READS
"DON'T TREAD ON ME," IT'S BEEN A
PRO LIBERTY SYMBOL FOR ALMOST
250 YEARS BUT WHEN ACTOR CHRIS
PRATT WORE A SHIRT WITH THE
FLAG, YAHOO WHICH IS THE
SORT OF NEWS ORGANIZATION, RAN
AN ARTICLE SUGGESTING THAT SHIRT
CHOICE REFLECTED "WHITE
SUPREMACY."
DEAN CAIN IS AN ACTOR AND STAR
IN THE RECENT FILM "GOSNELL."
WE SPOKE TO HIM AND HERE'S WHAT
HE SAID.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
STICK ALWAYS A PLEASURE, ALWAYSA
PLEASURE.
I'M STUNNED.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S SHOCKING TO ME.
I'M WEARING A SHIRT RIGHT NOW.
OH, MY GOSH.
IT SAYS COFFEE OR DIE BUT IT'S
SAID JOIN OR DIE IN THE OLD
DAYS.
BENJAMIN FRANKLIN POLITICAL
CARTOON BACK IN THE DAY.
THERE IS NOTHING RACIST ABOUT
THE GASTON FLAG.
IT SYMBOLIZES LIBERTY AND
INDEPENDENCE AND PART OF THE
REASON THEY GO AFTER CHRIS PRATT
FOR THAT IS BECAUSE CHRIS PRATT
IS A BIG SUPPORTER OF OUR
MILITARY.
HE HAS PLAYED NAVY SEALs AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
HE WAS THERE FOR THE CHALLENGE.
TROOPS LIKE HIM AND RESPECT HIM
AND A LOT OF OUR TROOPS LIKE
THAT FLAG AS WELL.
IT'S NOTHING BUT INDEPENDENCE
AND FREEDOM THAT I CAN SEE A
THING ABOUT IT THAT'S RACIST OR
WHITE SUPREMACY OR ANYTHING OF
THAT NATURE.
MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE THEY THINK HE
IS CONSERVATIVE AND THEY WANT TO
ATTACK HIM.
>> Tucker: SO, I'M SURE THAT'S
TRUE.
I SENSE A PATTERN.
OUR EARLIEST FLANKS, OUR
NATIONAL ANTHEM, OUR STATUES,
OUR HISTORY ITSELF, WHERE THEY
ARE REALLY ARGUING IS THAT
AMERICA IS A COUNTRY IS
LEGITIMATE.
>> UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S WHAT
THEY ARE ARGUING.
WE DID NOT HAVE A PERFECT
BEGINNING.
NO COUNTRY HAS.
WE ARE STRIVING FOR A MORE
PERFECT UNION.
MEANING THAT WE WERE NEVER
PERFECT TO BEGIN WITH.
WE WILL NEVER BE PERFECT.
WE WILL CONTINUALLY TRY TO MAKE
IT BETTER AND BETTER.
BUT JUST BECAUSE THOSE THINGS
HAPPENED IN THE PAST -- WE ARE
FORGED FROM THAT HISTORY.
YOU KNOW, THOSE THINGS SHOULDN'T
BE TAKEN DOWN.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE POOH-POOHED,
AND PEOPLE CAN'T CO-OPT THEM IF
YOU DON'T LET THEM.
THIS FLAG, IT'S A BIG PART OF
OUR HERITAGE.
SO MANY OF MY FRIENDS LOVE THE
GADSDEN FLAG.
THE "DON'T TREAD ON ME" SYMBOL
OF THE RATTLESNAKE WHO IS
ETERNALLY VIGILANT AND WON'T
ATTACK YOU UNLESS PROVOKED, IT'S
A BIG SYMBOL FOR THE
UNITED STATES AND IT STILL IS.
>> Tucker: AND FOR GOOD
REASON.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
BUT IT'S EASY FOR YOU AND ME TO
SAY THAT.
GIVE MY OPINIONS FOR LIVING.
YOU ARE COMPLETELY OUT OF THE
CLOSET.
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT YOUR VIEWS ARE.
YOU'VE TAKEN YOUR LUMPS ALREADY.
PEOPLE LIKE CHRIS PRATT WHO
AREN'T EXPLICITLY POLITICAL,
IT'S DANGEROUS, ISN'T IT, TO BE
CALLED NAMES?
>> IN VERY WELL COULD BE.
PORTLY FOR ME I'M OLD ENOUGH TO
FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT, DOESN'T
MATTER TO ME.
I WILL VOICE MY OPINION.
I'M NOT RACIST IN ANY WAY,
SHAPE, OR FORM.
I'M NOT COMPLETELY WHITE BUT
I'VE BEEN CALLED A WHITE THE
PREMISES.
I'VE BEEN CALLED A NAZI.
I'VE BEEN CALLED ALL THOSE
THINGS.
IT'S CRAZINESS.
PEOPLE ARE DOING THAT -- PEOPLE
LIKE CHRIS PRATT, THE GUYS A
MAJOR MOVIE STAR.
I THINK IS A FANTASTIC ACTOR,
VERY FUNNY.
IT COULD BE DANGEROUS FOR A GUY
LIKE THAT.
ABSOLUTELY.
AND THAT'S NOT OKAY.